[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سي
ابي عاصفه الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى بدايتنا من واشنطن
واعلان وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات
على مسؤولين في قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان بمن فيهم شقيق قائدي هذه القوات
وهذه الصور تريدنا من باريس وتاكيد متحدثا
باسم الحكومه الفرنسيه وجود محادثات بين
مسؤولين عسكريين من فرنسا والنيجر
الى كياف وزياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن تزامنا مع اعلان البيت
الابيض مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
البرهان يصدر قرارا بحل قوات الدعم السريع
الايجاد تدعو لاجتماع مباشرا بين طرفي
النزاع في السودان وتوحيد كل مبادرات
السلام لحل النزاع بشكل كامل تمديد اممي
وامريكي بانتهاكات الدعم في دارفور واشنطن
تفرض عقوبات على قياديين في الدعم السريع
من بينهما شقيق وحميتي
قوات الاحتلال تقتحم مخيم جنين للمره
الثانيه خلال يومين الفصائل الفلسطينيه
تتصدى وفي القدس عمليه طعن عند باب الخليل
تستهدف مستوطنين والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
تقول ان العمليه رد على جرائم الاحتلال
يؤكد من امتياز دعم واشنطن لاوكرانيا على
المدى البعيد
البنتاجون يعلن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده
تشمل مضادات للدروع والدبابات مزوده
باليورانيوم المنظم كوليبا يجدد المطالبات
بانظمه الدفاع الجوي والكريم لن يتهم
واشنطن بالعمل على اطاله امد الحرب على
حساب الاوكرانيين
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا سياقه تاكيد باريس بدء
محادثات بين عسكريين من فرنسا والنيجر بعد
يوم من كشف صحيفه
ستسحب بعض قواتها من النيجر لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي في رايكم ما هي ابرز رسائلي
اجراء محادثات بين مسؤولين عسكريين من
فرنسا والنيجر وجاءت ردودكم على نحو
التالي 50% اعتبروا الخطوه تراجعا في موقف
باريس حيال بقاء القوات الفرنسيه بالنيجر
16% قالوا ان المحادثات تاتي في سياق
تامين القوات الفرنسيه في النيجر بينما
راى 34% ان المحادثات محاوله لتخفيف
التوتر بين باريس وقاده الانقلاب
هذا السؤال سابقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مع اعلان مرصد كوبرنيكوس الاوروبي ان 2023
هي السنه الاكثر خصوم سخونه على الارجح
على مر التاريخ غوتيان الشقول ان الانهيار
المناخي قد بدا
[موسيقى]
نبدا اذا من التطورات في السودان حيث اصدر
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
مرسوما دستوريا قد بحل قوات الدعم السريع
وقال ان القرار صدر استنادا لتداعيات ما
وصفه بتمرد قوات الدعم على الدوله
والانتهاكات الجسيمه التي مارستها ضد
المواطنين والتخريب المتعمد للبنى التحتيه
بالبلاد بحسب بيان صادر عن اعلام مجلس
السياده الانتقالي
في هذه الاثناء افاد مراسل الجزيره بتواصل
الاشتباكات العنيفه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع في محيط سلاح المدرعات بمنطقه جبرا
جنوبيه الخرطوم كما اطلقت قوات الدعم
السريع قذائف هاون على معسكر سلاح
المهندسين بام درمان في هذه الاثناء قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ان عناصر من الدعم السريع ارتكبت فضائع
وانتهاكات بحق مدنيين في دارفور معلنا فرض
عقوبات على نائب قائد قوات الدعم السريع
وقائد قوات الدعم في دارفور
قتالهم غير الكثير تبدلت ملامح العاصمه
الوادعه مدنها الثلاث
صار الخوف يسكن ابناء الخرطوم التي تشهد
اشرس المعارك منذ بدء الحرب
بعضها يدور بالاسلحه الثقيله في محيط سلاح
المدرعات وبعضها في ارض المعسكرات
والمدينه الرياضيه وكذا قرب معسكر سلاح
المهندسين في ام درمان اشتباكات وتبادل
للقصف بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع المنشغل كلاهما بتحقيق مكاسب
ميدانيه
وبينما هم كذلك قل ان ينتبه المتحاربون
الى احوال من ليسوا طرفا في القتال اولئك
الذين يخوضون حربهم الخاصه للبقاء على قيد
الحياه مع تزايد سقوط الضحايا المدنيين من
جرائم قصف الاحياء السكنيه
وذاك ما يتقاذف الطرفان المتقاتلان تهمه
المسؤوليه عنه
فما تما يسعى لتحديد المسؤوليات عما يحدث
في الخرطوم وكذلك في كوردوفان ودارفور
اللتين اتسعت اليهما اعمال القتال
مستشاره الامم المتحده الخاصه المعنيه
بمنع الاباده الجماعيه اليس اندريتو عبرت
عن قلقها ازاء استمرار مستويات ما وصفته
بالعنف على اساس الهويه في عدد من
الولايات والمناطق بالسودان
وقالت ديريتو انها تلقت تقارير عن قيام
قوات الدعم السريع والميليشيات المتحالفه
معها باعدام عشرات الاشخاص وجرح اخرين في
مستيري بغربيه دارفور ارتباط الدعم السريع
بدرفورد ان لم يبدا اليوم لكن تطورات ما
يزيد على اربعه شهور من الحرب افرزت مواقف
دوليه لافته من تلك القوات فهي واشنطن
تشاطر الامم المتحده اتهامها عناصر من
قوات الدعم السريع بارتكاب فضائح
وانتهاكات بحق المدنيين في اقليم دارفور
بغربي السودان يقول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ان بين تلك الانتهاكات عمليات
قتل بدوافع عرقيه وانتهاكات بحق مدنيين
ونشطاء انتوني بلينكن اعلنت اتخاذ وزارتي
الخارجيه والخزانه في بلاده اجراءات ضد
اثنين من كبار قاده قوات الدعم السريع على
خلفيه ما وصفت بانتهاكات جسيمه لحقوق
الانسان
ولن نرجع يقصد شقيقه نائبه قائد قوات
الدعم عبد الرحيم دقلو وكذا قائد قوات
الدعم في غرب دارفور عبد الرحمن جمعه تقول
واشنطن انها لن تتردد في استخدام الادوات
المتاحه لاعاقه قدره قوه الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني على اطاله امد الحرب
لكن الحرب طالت واتسع مداها في ظل غياب
افق للحل السلمي او اي عمل حاسم يمنع
مزيدا من التصعيد التصعيد الحالي افرز
محنه انسانيه لا تفتا المنظمات الدوليه
تنبه الى مخاطر استفحالها هي محنه
يتقاسمها العالقون بين نيران المتحاربين
في ظروف قاسيه واولئك الذين تاخر عنهم
العون الانساني بعد اذ فروا الى مناطق
حاسبوها اكثر امنا داخل البلد وخارجه
قال قائد قوات الدعم السريع في غرب دارفور
اللواء عبد الرحمن جمعه بارك الله للجزيره
ان الدعم السريع لم يشارك في عمليات
عسكريه في مدينه جنينه وذلك التزاما
بتوجيهات القياده العليا للدعم السريع
واستنكر الارقام التي قدمها سلطان
المساليد والتي قدر بموجبها عدد القتلى
المدنيين في غرب دارفور بخمسه الاف قتيل
وكانت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه اقرت
عقوبات على القائد الثاني في الدعم السريع
عبد الرحيم دقلو وعلى قائد قوات الدعم
السريع بولايه غرب كردفان اللواء عبد
الرحمن جمعه بارك الله اسراء اتهامهما
بارتكاب جرائم حرب اثناء القتال في ولايه
غرب دارفور
عبرت الهيئه الحكوميه للتنميه ايجاد عن
قلقها من عدم تحسن الوضع في السودان مع
اتساع نطاق القتال الى مناطق نائيه ودالت
ايجاد في بيان من قمه الاليه الرباعيه
دانت الحرب في السودان ودعت الاطراف
المتحاربه للوقف الفوري لجميع الاعمال
العدائيه وفق تعبيرها وجددت الهيئه التزام
دول المجموعه الرباعيه بعقد اجتماع مباشرا
بين الاطراف المتحاربه في السودان
وتحدثت عن تعبئه مليون دولار من كل دوله
عضو في الهيئه لتقديم المساعده الانسانيه
وادعم السلام بالسودان حسب تعبيرها
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الباشا طبيق عضو
المجلس الاستشاري لقائد قوات الدعم
الساريه مرحبا بك سيد الباشا تطبيق كيف
تلقت قوات الدعم السريع هذا القرار من
جانب البرهان بحلها
مرحبا بكم استاذي الكريم والتحيه لك
والتحيه
للشعب السوداني
وعبرك ايضا التحيه للمستمعين قناه الجزيره
حقيقه قرار البرهان هو قرار غير دستوري
وقرار غير قانوني لذلك قوات الدعم السريع
لا تعترف بهذا القرار وهي اصلا لا تعترف
بالفريق البرهان رئيسا لمجلس السياده
البرهان الان هو يمثل الجيش وهو قائد يعني
للقوات المسلحه للجيش ولكن لا شرعيه له
وهو
الدستوريه التي اتت به رئيس المجلس
الزياده بالقاء العمل بالوثيقه الدستوريه
لذلك الان هو لا شرعيه له وهو لا يمثل
يعني السياده في السودان هو انقلب على
الشرعيه في 25
اكتوبر ولكن سيد الباشا الحكومه المدنيه
يعني ان كان غير شرعيه فهذا بنظركم وجهه
نظركم وهذا الانقلاب الذي كما تسميه تتحدث
عنه كان ايضا مساندا له السيد حميدتي الان
هناك قرار بحل الدعم السريع وبالتالي
اصبحت الدعم السريع بالفعل
تمرد كما كان يصفها البرهان منذ البدايه
ماذا انتم فاعلون ازاء ذلك
قرار المرار هو قرار غير دستوري يا استاذي
الكريم كما ذكرت لك من قبل وهذا القرار لا
يعني قوات الدعم السريع بشيء وهو من قبل
اصدر نفس هذا القرار لما كان البرهان في
مخبئه بالقياده العامه في البدروم في
بدايه الحرب مصدر غرار بحلق هذا الدعم
السريع وقراره هذا يعني لا يمثل
من الكتب به لذلك يعني اؤكد لك تماما ان
هذا القرار قرار غير دستوري وقرار غير
قانوني ولا يعني قوات الدعم السريع بشيء
هو الان يقود حربه وهو يمثل يعني قياده
الجيش ولا يمثل السياده الوطنيه للدوله
السودانيه نحن لا نعترف بالمره الان هو
رئيسا لمجلس السياده بالتزامن مع هذا
القرار او قبله بقليل صدرت عقوبات من
الولايات المتحده على قياديين في قوات
الدعم السريع احدهما هو شقيق قائد قوات
الدعم السريع ايضا كيف ستتعاملون مع هذه
العقوبات ومع هذا الواقع الجديد الذي يفرض
عليكم
انا اتحفظ على التعليق على هذا القرار
الامريكي حتى يصدر بيان رسمي من قوات
الدعم السريع اتحفظ على التعليق على هذا
القرار طيب اشكرك حتى الساعه الباشا تطبيق
عود المجلس الاستشاري لقائد قوات الدعم
السريع ضيفنا من الخرطوم
معنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديميه السودانيه المختص في
الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه مرحبا بك
الدكتور اسامه اذا وفق الدعم السريع وما
افادنا به السيد باشا تطبيق هذا القرار
قرار حلق قوات الدعم السريع هو غير قانوني
وغير دستوري
هو هذا القرار اعاد قوات الدعم السريع الى
اصلها انها قوه متمرده على الدوله
السودانيه
تحمل تستند على قوه السلاح وتستند على حشد
مجموعات من المرتزقه بالاضافه الى الجنود
الذين كانوا جزءا من قوات الدعم السريع
عندما انشات بقانون
فالدوله السودانيه الان تتخلص من حموله
الدعم السريع
ويعني ليس جديدا المناداه
بحل الدعم السريع دمج الدعم السريع هذه
يعني
من الذي مكن الدعم السريع وجراها على هذا
الوضع واعطاها كل هذه الادوات الجيش
والدوله السودانيه الدوله السودانيه اخطات
خطا استراتيجي خلال الاربع سنوات الماضيه
في تمكين الدعم السريع ووصوله الى هذه هذا
المستوى ونقل الحرب الى الخرطوم هو نجاح
استراتيجي لقوات الدعم السريع هذه حقائق
لا يمكن
لكن هذه الحقائق هذه القوات بدا يعني هي
ليست نفس القوات التي بدات الحرب في 15
ابريل الان هذه القوات تحولت الى قوات
تحارب الشعب السوداني قوات مجموعه من
عصابات النهب والسلب والمجرمين في اوساطها
مجموعه من المرتزقه من خارج السودان
انضموا الى عملياتها بالاضافه الى ابناء
السودان فيها لكن قرار حل هذه القوات ماذا
ستكون مفاعيله على الارض كيف
يمكن تطبيقه على الارض عمليا هو عمليا اول
شيء هذه القوات الان يعني تخلصت الدوله من
حمولتها وبالتالي ليس لها اي شرعيه
قانونيه داخل دوله السودان ولا خارجها
واظن انه لها ارتباط ايضا بالقرار
الامريكي الذي يعني هو قرار في بداياته
هذا القرار سيتصاعد ضد قوات الدعم السريع
في حمله جدا يعني ضد الجرائم ضد الانسانيه
التي ترتكبها ضد الشعب السوداني الان
وستصل الى تجميد اموال كثيره جدا غير
اموال عبد الرحيم وهو المسؤول الاول عن
العمل التجاري والعمل يعني عمال التجاريه
والاداره اموال الدعم السريع فهذه
العقوبات ستطال اموال الدعم السريع كمؤسسه
والان هي كانت مؤسسه تتبع للدوله
السودانيه وتم حلها فاموالها كمؤسسه تعود
للدوله السودانيه وربما هذا يحميها من
قرارات التجميد القادمه اظن هذا توحيد
القرار ايضا في غضون ذلك الحرب مستمره على
الارض ولا شيء كل هذه الاجراءات المتخذه
العقوبات الامريكيه وايضا قرار الحال كيف
من شانه ان يؤثر على ما يجري على الارض
عمليا العقوبات الامريكيه لها جانبان اولا
يعني اعتراف المجتمع الدولي بالجرائم التي
تدور من قبل قوات الدعم السريع ضد الشعب
السوداني هذا يدفع بالقضيه الى الامام
ويفسرها تفسير صحيحه لانه حتى القرار
الامريكي نادى الجهات الخارجيه التي تعمل
على اطاله الحرب في السودان ان تتوقف عن
دعم الدعم السريع في حربه ضد الشعب
السوداني فهذا اجراء يضيف لكن القرار
الامريكي نفسه لا يمكن تفسيره كله بانه في
صالح الشعب السوداني لانه هذه الحرب
الدائره في السودان هي جزء من الصراع
الموجود في منطقه الساحل وتتداخل فيه
اطراف دوليه كثيره جدا وحركه الاموال
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقييد
حركه الاموال هو ايضا من وسائل السيطره
على الصراع الدائر في منطقه الساحل
والصحراء كلها شكرا لك دكتور اسامه عيدروس
الاكاديمي السودانيه المختص للشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه ضيفنا هنا
[موسيقى]
اعتقلت شرطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في القدس
فتى فلسطينيا بتهمه تنفيذه عمليه طعام عند
باب الخليل في القدس وفق بيان شرطه فقد
اصيب اسرائيليان في العمليه جروح احدهما
خطيره واضافت الشرطه انه تم نقل المنفذ
الى مركز التحقيق
وفي ردود الفعل على عمليه الطعن في القدس
قالت حركه حماس ان العمليه تاتي في اطار
الرد الطبيعي للمقاومه على جرائم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بينما قالت حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ان من حق الشعب الفلسطيني التصدي
للعدوان والرد على جرائم القتل وانتهاك
الاعراض من قبل جنود الاحتلال
في الاثناء انسحبت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من مدينه جنين ومحيط مخيم جنين
بعد اعتقالها محمد نغنغيه احد قاده كتائب
شهداء الاقصى الذراع العسكريه لحركه فتح
من منزله وكانت قوات الاحتلال نفذت عمليه
خاطفه شاركت فيها قوات خاصه تبعتها عشرات
الاليات واستهدفت منزل نغنغيه وهو اسير
محرر وشقيق لشهدين وقالت فصائل المقاومه
ان مقاتليها تبادلوا اطلاق النار على اكثر
من محور مع هذه القوات التي توغلت من
مدخلي المدينه الشمالي والغربي
مع كل توغل اسرائيلي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه ومع كل
انتهاك يتعرض له المواطن الفلسطيني كما
حدث مع النساء الفلسطينيات على يد قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مؤخرا ومع كل توسع في
الاستيطان ينشا السؤال عن القضيه
الفلسطينيه ما افاق حلها في ظل تجاهل
دوليا واقليمي وما مصير المشروع الوطني
الفلسطيني الذي يتم التواطؤ على افراغه من
كونه قضيه سياسيه الى مجرد معضله امنيه
تقرير فوزي بشرى
في عالم لم يعد ينشغل بالقضيه الفلسطينيه
وفي محيط عربي صار التحذير من التصعيد
قصار جهده اصبح الفلسطيني يواجه وحده
معركه وجوده في الحياه معركه الارض ومعركه
بقائه عليها
تنشط اسرائيل في التعقب المقاومه قتلا
واعتقاله في مخيم جنين وفي مدن الضفه
الغربيه او تدخل في مغامره المساس بعرض
المراه الفلسطينيه فتزداد المقاومه تماسكا
وتمحي بينها الفروق والفصائليه تم حلف
الجغرافيا ما بين غزه وما بين الضفه
الغربيه وتمتد عقيده فداء الانسان والارض
الى ما وراء الخط الاخضر
في القدس سيجد الفلسطيني نفسه مره اخرى
يقوم بعبئ التصدي الانتهاكات المسجد
الاقصى الذي تقدسه 57 دوله هي اعضاء منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي وتتركه وشانه 57 دوله
بتمامها الا من خطبه مستنكره
لا شيء تغير في سيره الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الا ازدياده في التطرف وفي اصطناع خطاب
جديد يشرع توحش قوته عبر زعم يقول بانه لا
وجود لما يسمى بالضفه الغربيه لانها جزء
من ارض اسرائيل ولانها كذلك فهي ارض يحق
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي استباحتها متى شاء
اما الزعم الاخر فيقوم على نفي وجود الشعب
الفلسطيني نفسه وهذه المزاعم هي ما يشكل
خطاب اليمين الصهيوني الديني الذي يقدم
فصلا اخر من عنف الدوله الصهيونيه ويجد
ترجمته العمليه على الارض بعنف يخير
الفلسطيني بين التسليم بالامر الواقع
تماما كالسلطه الفلسطينيه التي صارت تقدم
وصفا للجريمه ثم تستنكرها
ذلك داب ما خرجت عليه الا لتعود اليه وبين
خيار اخر يصل الفلسطيني بالارهاب ومن ثم
يبرر قتله اذا تصدر المشروع الصهيوني لمحو
الفلسطيني انسانا وارضا من المؤمنين رجال
صدقوا معهدوا الله عليه
هذا التصدي يتخذ عنوانا كبيرا هو المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والمقاومه هي اخر القلاع بعد
سقوط الحواضن العربيه في التطبيع مع
اسرائيل ونفضها يدها من تبعات القضيه
الفلسطينيه ورفض اليد هو حاله تضعك في
احسن الاحوال موضع المعلق السياسي على
الاحداث يصفها ولا ينخرط فيها جاء في
الاخبار ان الامين العام للجامعه العربيه
احمد ابو الغيط قال ان القضيه الفلسطينيه
تواجه التحديات خطيره ما الذي تستدعيه
التحديات الخطيره من يجيبك ابو الغيط ولا
احد غيره اما الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
فهو معلق اخر كشان ابي الغيط فهو يقول ان
اعمال اسرائيل الاحاديه وارهاب المستوطنين
يسهم في توتير الاجواء
ومثل ابي الغيث لا يقدم عباس حلا انه يصف
وحسب مشكله السلطه الفلسطينيه انها في
سبيل تحقيق صفاء الاجواء وهو صفاء لا
يستقيم عقلا في وجود الاحتلال مشكله
السلطه انها تجد نفسها من اجل هذا الصفاء
المتوهم في مواجهه مع شعبها كما ذكرت
صحيفه في تقرير لها قال ان السلطه في سبيل
بقائها تقاتل شعبها في هذا السياق الذي
تضيق خياراته على الشعب الفلسطيني تبدو
المقاومه بقليل سلاحها وكثير عزمها
وارادتها مصممه على الوقوف في وجه المشروع
الصهيوني المستهدف لفكره الدوله
الفلسطينيه وجعلها مجرد خطاب سياسي بلا
مظلوم
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه الممتده والمتجدده
عبر الاجيال تعمل اليوم في ظروف كلها غير
مواطن فاله العالم الغربي الاعلاميه وخطاب
ساسته لا يتردد في وصف فعل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالارهاب لكنه يمتدح مثلا
شجاعه الاوكراني في حربه لتحرير ارضه
الفلسطيني لا يمتدحه احد انه يقف في بريه
الله وحده يتوارث الشهاده داخل الاسره
الواحده حفيدا عن اب عن جد ويتوارث عبء
صناعه التاريخ في زمان لم يعد فيه احد
معنيا بكتابه سطر فيه مضيء
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام الله
الدكتور هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات
لابحاث السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
مرحبا بك دكتور هاني المصري طبعا الزميل
فوزي بشرى اخذنا الى صوره اوسع لما يجري
ولكن لنعود الى ما حصل اليوم تحديدا عمليه
القدس ما الدلالات التي قراتها من هذه
العمليه
عمليه القدس مثل عمليه الاغوار مثل
المقاومه في جنين ونابلس وفي كل مكان تدل
على ان الشعب الفلسطيني والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه لن تقبل ان تكون مجرد ضحيه
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف اعتداء اسرائيلي نفذ
ضد الفلسطينيين في شهر اب الماضي وهناك كل
يوم اقتحامات وهدم منازل وجرف بيوت
ومنع الناس من حريه الحركه مئات الحواجز
تقطع اوصال الضفه الغربيه وما تم فعله
بالحرائر في الخليل كل هذا يدل على
نيه الاحتلال وما في جعبته هذا الامر لا
يقابله الفلسطيني بالصمت او السكينه او
الاستسلام وانما يقاومه برد فعل طبيعي هو
الدفاع عن نفسه الدفاع عن حقوقه الدفاع عن
ناسه وهذا امر اثبت فيه الشعب الفلسطيني
في هذا العام اكثر من الاعوام السابقه انه
مستعد لايقاع خسائر في الاحتلال وفي قوات
الاحتلال وفي المستوطنين وهذا الشيء جعل
الاحتلال لا يعرف ماذا يدري يفعل يجرب
المجرب
هذه الخسائر التي يتمكن تتمكن المقاومه
الفلسطينيه من الحاقها
بالاسرائيليين ما هو صداها في داخل
اسرائيل وما فعاليتها تجاه هذه العمليات
التي يقوم بها جيش الاحتلال
اولا هذه العمليات تحرج الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه خاصه انها ادعت انها
حكومه قادره على الحسم وفيها وزراء في
منتهى التطرف يقولون ان لديهم القدره على
معالجه الموضوع الفلسطيني كما لم تعالجه
الحكومات الاسرائيليه السابقه الخسائر
الاسرائيليه في ظل هذه الحكومه اكثر من
الخسائر في ظل الحكومات السابقه وبالتالي
هذا يحرج يعني حكومه الاحتلال احراجا
كبيرا ونراها تتخبط لا تعرف ماذا تفعل
تاره تهدد بالاغتيالات طارت تهدد بالحرب
الشامله طارتها تهدد بقتل الفلسطينيين مثل
ما سمعنا يعني بنك فيري اليوم يقول ان
مكانهم القبر ولكن في النتيجه لا يمكن
الغاء وجود اكثر من سبعه مليون فلسطيني
على ارض وطنه ومثلهم في الخارج لا يزالون
يتمشكون بالقضيه الفلسطيني الاسرائيليه
يزداد الاستيطان ازداد التوغل
او او التغول الاسرائيلي عفوا ضد
الفلسطينيين
نعم معك حق هناك كثافه بالاعمال
الاسرائيليه على مختلف الاصعده اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف مستعمر دخلوا المسجد الاقصى في
الشهر الماضي هناك مئات عمليات اطلاق
الرصاص التي تقوم بها قوات الاحتلال ضد
الفلسطينيين في كل شهر واكثر من 500 معتقل
في كل شهر ولكن كل هذا لا يقضي على
المقاومه وبالتالي تزيد قوات الاحتلال من
جبروتها ومن عنفها ومن بطشها ويكون هناك
صمود ودفاع ومقاومه ورغم الاحتلال الفادع
في ميزان القوه لا نستطيع ان نحاسب
الفلسطيني لانه لم يكن قادرا مساء على
تحرير الارض الان مجرد بقائه واستمرار
مقاومته وتمسكه بقضيته هذا هو يعني
الانجاز الحقيقي نحن في مرحله دفاع نحن في
مرحله الصمود الى ان تتوفر متطلبات
المواجهه وهذه بحاجه الى استراتيجيه
فلسطينيه واحده بحاجه الى انهاء الانقسام
بحاجه الى عمق عربي ودولي يدعم الشعب
الفلسطيني ليس بشكل عام وليس بشكل لفظي
فقط وانما دعم حقيقي لانه بدا من مكافاه
حكومه الاحتلال شكرا البحث عن تطبيع معها
وهي اكثر حكومه متطرفه يجب معاقبتها
ومساءلتها شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور هاني
المصري مدير مركزي مسارات لابحاث السياسات
ودراسات الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكن عن دعم جديد تقدمه بلاده لاوكرانيا
بقيمه مليار دولار اضاف خلال مؤتمر صحفي
مع نظيره الاوكراني بكياس ان الولايات
المتحده ستواصل دعم الشعب الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
الدعم العسكري والاقتصادي الذي يقدم
لاوكرانيا ليس عملا خيريا انها استثمارات
في مجال الامن ذات مردود عال وهي مهمه
للعالم كله والسيد الوزير سوف يعود
لواشنطن بفهم وادراك لكل ما نحتاج له وقد
تحدثنا عن زياده الدعم في انظمه الدفاع
الجوي وقد راى الوزير بنفسه اليوم الهجمات
على كيف لذلك لم يستغرق الحديث عن انظمه
الدفاع الجوي وقتا طويلا لان كل شيء كان
واضحا
اليوم اعلنا عن مساعدات باكثر من مليار
دولار دعما لاوكرانيا منها اكثر من 665
مليون دولار كمساعدات عسكريه وبدنيه الى
جانب ثلاثه واربعين مليار دولار قدمناها
للاوكرانيين منذ بدء العدوان الروسي
ومن موسكو قال الكريم ان الدعم الامريكيه
المقدم لكييف لن يغير نتيجه ما سماه
العمليه الروسيه الخاصه في اوكرانيا اضافت
الرئاسه الروسيه ان واشنطن تدفع باوكرانيا
الى حرب حتى اخر اوكراني من خلال مدها بكل
الوسائل الممكنه
ينضم الينا من كييف الدكتور فولوديمير
شوماكنوف
الدبلوماسيه الاوكراني السابق ومعنى من
بوستن الدكتور
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
والباحث في قضايا الامن الدولي مرحبا بكما
سنبدا معك دكتور ماكس ابرامز هذه هي
الزياره الاولى التي يقوم بها الى كييف
منذ انطلاق الهجوم المضاد اي دلالات حملت
باعتقادك ونحن نعلم في الخلفيه انها كانت
هناك انتقادات وجهت الى النتائج التي حقق
هذا الهجوم
اعتقد ان توقيت هذه الزياره مهم
[موسيقى]
كان هنالك نفاذ الصبر متزايد في الولايات
المتحده تجاهها توجهي الحرب كان هنالك
الكثير من المسؤولين الامريكيين والخبراء
الذين قبل اشهر عديده وعدوا بان الهجمه
المضاده ستاتي بطريقه
سريعه وسلسه وكل ما نحتاجه هو ان يكون
هنالك في بدايه الهجمه المضاده من اجل ان
نرى بدايه لاعاده السيطره على الاراضي في
اوكرانيا بدلا من ذلك فان الهجمه المضاده
كان مسارها بطيء الدفاعات الروسيات تم
تقليل
امكانياتها وبشكل متزايد في وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه نرى الكثير من الشكوى وخيبه
الامل والاكثر من ذلك سياسيا داخل
الولايات المتحده فان
المرش الثلاثه هم يتعون الى تقليل كبير
للمساعده الامريكيه لاوكرانيا وفي وفي
برامج
ويعبرون ان ويقولون ان اغلب الامريكيين لا
يدعمون هذا هذه المساعدات بالتالي التوقيت
مهم هو مختلف عن ما كان عليه الوضع قبل
اربع اشهر وقبل ذلك والوزير بلينكن الان
يحاول ان يؤشر الى
كل اوكراني ان امريكا تستمر بدعم اوكرانيا
طيب ولكن
دكتور
اتوجه اليك دكتور فولوديمير شوماكوف في
كييف باعتقادك كيف تعاملت القياده
الاوكرانيه مع هذه الانتقادات خلف الابواب
لانه
في العلن كان هناك حديث عن دعم ودعم لا
متناهي لاوكرانيا ولكن خلف الابواب كيف
تعاملت اوكرانيا مع هذه الانتقادات لنتائج
الهجوم المضاد
ولكن هذه المساعده
بحجم مليار دولار مهم لاوكرانيا اكيد ولكن
ثاني واحد
اوكرانيا لم تحصل على مقاتلات من طرازك 16
اوكرانيا لم تحصل على صواريخ بعيده ماذا
واوكرانيا لم تحصل على
وكمان مروحيات بالمناسبه يعني بصفه عامه
ينبغي ادراك نحن نقاتل مع جيش رقم اثنين
على المستوى العالم
لاختراق خطوط الدفاعيه خاطئه الدفاع الاول
اوكرانيا اختارك طولي اختراق اثنين خطوط
الاخرى اوكرانيا تحتاج زياده من الموعدات
العسكريه ومنها مقاتلات ومنها صواريخ
بعدما يعني خطوط الدفاعيه روسيه معذرتها
هذا عموما تحصينات عسكريه حتى تحت الارض
موجود تحصينات عسكريه تحت خطوط الدفاعيه
الروسيه دكتور ما رايك
يقول ضيفنا من اوكرانيا ان بالنهايه
اوكرانيا لم تحصل على كل المساعدات
العسكريه التي تمكنها فعلا من الاحراز هذا
التقدم الذي ينشده الغرب
نعم انا مطلع على هذا هذه المقاربه
اوكرانيا في وضع صعب للغايه هي تقاتل ضد
قوه عسكريه عظمى واوكرانيا تحاول ان تقود
الهجوم الان وهذا امر صعب لان الروس
دفاعاتهم حصينه بالتالي الامر ليس مفاجئا
على الاطلاق ان المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
يستمرون بقول هذا الامر هذا الامر مستمر
ومستمروا بطلب المزيد والمزيد من الاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه من اجل السيطره على
الاجواء وطلبوا مقاتلات اف 16
والمضي اعمق ربما داخل روسيا بالتالي من
وجهه نظر الامريكيه الان فان هذا الامر
يبدو وكانه ما يسمى الحرب الى الابد الحرب
البلاد نهايه ليس واضح متى ستنتهي هذه
الحرب شحنات الاسلحه قد تتطلب وقتا طويلا
للنقل ولتدريب الاوكرانيين على استخدامها
واعتقد ان الامريكيين الان بداوا يطرحون
الاسئله والى اي متى سنستمر بالاستثمار
استثمار في
اموال دافعيه الضرائب من اجل تمويل هذه
الحرب والاكثر من ذلك هنالك قلق مستمر من
الامريكيين واعتقدوا انهم مبرر وفحواه انه
اذا ما قامت بتجيء الولايات المتحده
بتجهيز الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا بشكل ربما
عدائي اكبر قد يزيد من عدائيه روسيا
وبالتالي يزيد من امكانيه الاستعمال الحرب
ستتصاعد بشكل اضافي
دكتور ماكس دكتور فولوديمير شوماكوف اليوم
زيلينسكي يتحدث امام بلينكن عن شتاء صعب
بانتظار اوكرانيا وبانتظار الجبهات ماذا
يعني عم ليا هذا الكلام لو اخذنا بعين
الاعتبار ما قاله الدكتور ماكس عن انه
بروز الاسئله الان هل هذه الحرب هي حرب
الى الابد
رئيس روسي هو اخذ قرارنا حول حول حرب
الاستنزاف وهو غير استراتيجيه بصفه عامه
ويعني نلاحظون ان القرار حول انتهاء لحربه
هو في بوتين ولكن هو اختار حرف الطويله
الامد ولذلك نحن في حاجه ماسه الى مواعظات
عسكريه هجوميه كما نقول
ثمير الغرب يتحدث عن قصور في التكتيكات
العسكريه على الارض ومن هنا اتى هذا
الاجتماع بين قيادات عسكريه اوكرانيه
وقيادات في عسكريه في النيتو في بولندا من
اجل تغيير التكتيكات على الارض يعني ليس
فقط من وجهه نظر الغرب الامر ليس فقط
مرتبط بالاسلحه
نعم صحيح وموجود
حول الاستراتيجيه الهجوميه اوكرانيه ولكن
لنكون صريحين هل توجد لدي امريكا ولدي دول
اخرى غربيه اي خبره في حرب مصر في حرب على
نطاق الواسع مثل نحن نقاتل مع روسيا اكيد
لا ثانيا اليوم كما نحن نشاهد بان هو اكد
بان هجوم المضادات واوكرانيا وهو ناجح
بصراحه يعرقل هجوم المضاد الاوكراني عده
الضخم من الالغام
في خطوط الالتماس
الوقت ليس في الصالح اوكرانيا اشكرك
الدبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه السابق ضيفنا من
كييف وشكرا من بوست للدكتور ماكس اي برامز
استاذه العلوم السياسيه في جامعه نورس
ايسترن والباحث في قضايا الامن الدولي
شكرا لك
وقبيل وصولي بلنكن تعرضت اوكرانيا
لاستهداف روسيا واسع النطاق التفاصيل في
التقرير التالي
هجوم واسع بصواريخ ومسيرات تتعرض له كييف
هجوم منسق يقول الجيش الاوكراني بصواريخ
وكروز تنطلق سفارات الانذار وتسقط
الدفاعات الجويه جميع الصواريخ بحسب الجيش
الاوكراني طال الهجوم معظم مقاطعات
اوكرانيا بما فيها الفيف في الغرب وفي
عداسا جنوبي البلاد 25 مسيره تستهدف
المدينه اسقطتها الدفاعات الجويه وكانت
تتجه لميناء تصدير الحبوب في منطقه
اسماعيل
بموازاه التطورات الميدانيه وصل وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
الى كييف زياره بلنكن تهدف للاستماع
لتقييم حقيقي حول تطورات الحرب من
الاوكرانيين انفسهم بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه
واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين امريكيين وتقول
المعلومات المتوفره ان واشنطن ستقر
مساعدات اضافيه تزيد على مليار دولار
لاوكرانيا بعدما اكدت كييف لوشنطن انها
تحتاج ذخيره وليس مشوره بحسب الصحيفه ومن
بين ما تطلبه نسخه محدثه من صاروخ امرام
ليغطي مسافه تتراوح بين 160
و180 كيلومترا وهو صاروخ جو جو متوسط
المدى يبلغ وزنه
52 كيلوغراما وطوله قرابه اربعه امتار
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
اكد ان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه طلب
التعديلات على الصاروخ واضاف بحسب وكاله
للاخبار ان الصاروخ سيمكن بلاده من ضرب
الطائرات الروسيه دون دخول منطقه الدفاع
الجوي في المقابل نقلت وكاله تاس ان
طائرات سوخوي 57
ستتزود قريبا بصواريخ من الجيل الخامس من
طراز ار 37
يتراوح مداها بين 150 و300 كم وهو صاروخ
فرط صوتي تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت بخمسه
اضعاف يستطيع الاشتباك مع اهداف طائره على
ارتفاع يتراوح بين 15 مترا الى 25 كلم
كل هذه الخطوات تصب في استراتيجيه عسكريه
مفادها ان من يتفوق في القدرات الجويه
يتفوق حتما في الحرب
نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن متحدثا باسم
السفاره الامريكيه في الامارات ان مسؤولين
من الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي وصلوا الى الامارات هذا الاسبوع
لمناقشه تنفيذ العقوبات على روسيا بسبب
حربها على اوكرانيا وذلك في اطار جهد اوسع
تقوم به تلك الدول مع مجموعه من الدول
الشريكه لضمان الالتزام بالعقوبات ونقلت
سي ان ان عن مسؤولا اماراتيا بارز قوله ان
الامارات تتعاون مع حلفائها واصدقائها
للتعامل مع اي بواعث قلق بشان العقوبات
المفروضه على روسيا وقالت سي ان ان
مسؤولين غربيين زاروا الامارات مرات عده
خلال العامين الماضيين للتحذير من ان
مساعده روسيا على تفادي العقوبات لن يمر
دون عواقب ونقلت عن المسؤول الاماراتي
قولها ان بلاده تلتزم بشكل صارم بالعقوبات
التي فرضتها الامم المتحده
نتابع الان التطورات الازمه في النيجر حيث
اكد مصدر في وزاره الدفاع الفرنسيه
للجزيره ان هناك عمليه تنسيق وظيفي متبادل
بين الجيش الفرنسي والقوات النيجيريه لسحب
معدات حساسه من القاعده العسكريه الفرنسيه
في نيامي ويجري الحديث عن نقل سريع لهذه
المعدات مع الطواقم المشغله لها الا ان
سحب القوات الفرنسيه ليس في اجنده
العسكريين الفرنسيين حسب المصادر ذاتها
سلمت فرنسا بالامر الواقع وبدات مباحثات
مع الجيش في النيجر لسحب قواتها من هناك
ملطفه الامر بتعبيرات من قبيل اعاده
انتشار وفقدان القدره على اداء المهمه
فيما سفارتها في شبه حصار مطوقه بالجنود
ومن خلفهم حشود وبهذا ينحصر طيف اخر من
العصر الفرنسي المستعمر التاريخي عن بلد
افريقي دون ان تتوضح تماما معالم العصر
القادم بينما تعيش دول افريقيه على وقع
هاجس واحد من التالي سؤال يوقد نيران الشك
فيتحسب ويحتاط من يخاف ويرتاب وتتخذ
تغيرات عسكريه في الكاميرون ورواندا جيران
الانقلابين المتواليين في غرب افريقيا
هناك عند الساحل الاطلسي الذي ظل لخمسه
قرون ممرا بغيضا العبوديه خدمه لدول
الاستعمار الغربي قديمها في اوروبا
وحديثها فيما كانت تعرف بالعالم الجديد
امريكا وظل النفس الاستعماري حاضرا حتى
اللحظات الاخيره في الاحداث الاخيره وبدا
بان لا سلطه شرعيه لزمره من الانقلابيين
لينتهي بالتفاوض والبحث عن ملاذات نفوذ
اخرى ومن المفارقه ان ترفع شعارات الحفاظ
على الديمقراطيه كمسوغ للتدخل سواء من
اوروبا او من المنظمات الاقليميه المعنيه
لكن بازدواجيه بين الغابون والنيجر ما
يرجعه مراقبون الى مدى تحقق المصلحه
الخارجيه من كل انقلاب على حده اما
الديمقراطيه فهي في منطقها الانساني وسيله
وغايه تتحقق في صلاح امر الناس وهذا ما لا
يجده الافارقه لا في المظهر المدني ولا
العسكري ويردونه الى سطوه الاستعمار فكثير
من الفرحين بالانقلابات هم اجيال متواليه
حائره في سر بقائها تعيسه مهمشه يقول
باحثون ان التحرر في بلدان غرب افريقيا
والساحل لم يتحقق فعليا باستقلال هذه
الدول منتصف القرن الماضي فالاستقلال ليس
نشيدا وعلما فلا لغه لاهل تلك البلاد سوى
الفرنسيه والانجليزيه والبرتغاليه يسكن
الاستعمار السنتهم فيما اشباحه تطل من
الشركات الاجنبيه العملاقه التي تستخرج
الموارد الهائله فيصلهم ما تتكفل نخب
الفساد الحاكمه بتبديده الناظر الى
الجابون لن يرى ما تكون عليه دول النفط
المزدره والناظر الى النيجر لا يشاع في
وجهه اليورانيوم الذي يضيء انوار باريس
المتلالئه انها القاره الاغنى الاشد فقره
والانقلابات التي تجاوزت 200 في سته عقود
لم تقدم لهم غير استبداد يغير رداءه لكن
المؤكد ان افريقيا تتغير وتنبئ احداثها
بتراجع نفوذ الغرب لتمثل براي كثر نموذجا
ماثلا لنشوء عالم متعدد الاقطاب ويبقى على
ابنائها ان يتم واجبات التحرر وهي كرامه
الانسان ورفاهه
[موسيقى]
قال الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
ان الانهيار المناخي قد بدا وجاء قوله هذا
تعليقا على اعلان مرصد كوبرنيكوس الاوروبي
ان صيف نصف الكره الارضيه الشمالي كان
الاكثر حرا على الاطلاق وكان المرصد قد
رجح ان يكون عام 2023 اكثر الاعوام سخونه
في التاريخ
العالم من شرقه الى غربه ومن شماله الى
جنوبه في مشهد متقلب بين مختلف انواع
الكوارث الطبيعيه وما ان تنتهي كارثه حتى
تبدا اخرى فاليونان لم تكت تنتهي من اخماد
الحرائق التي الهبت غاباتها منذ اسابيع
حتى وجدت نفسها تحت امطار غير مسبوقه
اغرقت بغزارتها الشوارع وجرفت مع كل شيء
حياه شخص على الاقل كل شيء عالق هناك الا
جريان المياه طرق محطمه وقلوب ايضا اغرقها
الحزن على ما فقدت
مشهد السيول الجارفه تكرر في بعض احياء
اسطنبول التركيه ورغم اعلان السلطات
انحسارها الا انها كانت قد اودت بحياه
اشخاص صادفتهم وهي في طريقها نحو تدمير
اكثر من 1700 منزل ومنشاه تجاريه
في الصين هناك تسمع دقات ناقوس الخطر
المناخي بقوه اكبر فقد مر الاعصار هايكوي
على البلاد وترك بها فيضانات غمرت شوارعها
وقوارب الانقاذ والاجلاء تاخذ طريقها تحت
زخات المطر وبين طيارات السيول فقد علقت
الدراسه واغلقت الطرق السريعه على الرغم
من اعلان تراجع قوه هايكوي بعد وصوله الى
اليابسه الى نصف العالم الجنوبي بالضبط في
البرازيل تغير المناخ هناك فاوده بحياه 21
شخصا في اعصار عصف بجنوبي البلاد لم يعد
ينتقل سكان ولايه جراند ديسون الا على
القوارب تحولت الشوارع هناك الى مسطحات
مائيه بدون معالم والامطار التي بلغت 300
متر خلال 24 ساعه جعلت اكثر من 25 الف شخص
في حوالي 60 بلده على حافه التشرد
في نفس المشهد من العالم وفي اقصى شماله
تودع الثلوج شيئا فشيئا جبال سويسرا وتاخذ
طريقها بين الفجاج مستسلمه للذوبان هكذا
يشاهد الخبراء كل يوم كيف تتحول الثلوج
الى مياه بفعل الاحتباس الحراري مؤكدين
بان تحولها كان سريعا جدا هذه السنه وبشكل
غير متوقع السنه التي اعلن مرصد كوبر
نيكوس الاوروبي ان صيفها شهد اعلى متوسط
لدرجات الحراره العالميه تم قياسه على
الاطلاق مرجحا ان تكون اكثر الاعوام سخونه
في التاريخ فيما اعرب الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو عن اسفه عندما قال بصريح
العباره ان الانهيار المناخي قد بدا ياتي
المشهد وسط الاصوات المطالبه باتخاذ
اجراءات تكبح مخاطر التغير المناخي خصوصا
في مناطق يقترب منها الخطر بشكل اكبر هذا
ما اكدت عليه قمه المناخ الافريقيه الاولى
واكدته مفاوضات دوليه اخرى حول المناخ
يتجدد صداها مع كل كارثه طبيعيه تنضاف الى
ملف التغير المناخي
فقره المتابعه في حصاد الليله نخصصها لرصد
ابرز المناطق المتضرره من النزاع في
السودان والوضع الانساني المتدهور تعتبر
العاصمه الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث ساحه
رئيسيه للمعارك بين جيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع حيث يشتد القتال العنيف في
احياء مقتظه بالسكان ويسقط يوميا قتل
وجرحى ويضطر مزيد من السكان للرحيل بحثا
عن ملاذ امن كما يشهد اقليم دارفور غربيه
السودان مواجهات متواصله بين الطرفين
لاسيما في مدينه نيالا على الحدود مع تشاد
التي غادرها اكثر من خمسين الف شخص بعد
تعطل شبكات الكهرباء والمياه والاتصالات
وتضرر المستشفيات
وتستاثر منطقه الحدود السودانيه الشاديه
بجانب كبير من الوضع الانساني المتفاقم
فمنها عبر نحو 400 الف شخص الى داخل تشاد
من اني زاعي قبل نحوي خمسه اشهر نحو نصف
اولئك اللاجئين استقر بهم المطاف بعد رحله
شاقه في مدينه ادريس شرقيه تشاد وغالبيتهم
نساء واطفال ومسنون يفتقدون الغذاء
والعنايه الطبيه ومرافق الصرف الصحي اما
مدينه بورتسودان شمال شرقي البلاد فهي
الوجهه الاولى
للفرينه من الخرطوم حيث يتقدس فيها عشرات
الاف النازحين قبل مواصله الرحله بحرا او
جوا لجوءا الى خارج السودان
المعاناه السودانيه المتناثره على جغرافيا
واسعه تشهد عليها احصائيات مفزعه ومنذره
بالاسوا وفق المنظمات الاغاثه المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره قالت ان حواليه سبعه
ملايين شخص نزحوا داخليا في السودان منذ
تفجر النزاع منتصف ابريل الماضي وتتوقع
المفوضيه العليا لشؤون اللاجئين التابعه
للامم المتحده نزوح مليون و700 الف شخص
اخرين بحلول نهايه العام وناشد التوفير
مليار دولار لمساعدتهم كما فر نحو مليون
سوداني الى دول الجوار وفي مقدمتها تشاد
بحوالي 400 الف لاجئ فلها مصر بنحو
ثلاثمائه الف لاجئ وجنوب السودان
بربع مليون لاجئ
للمزيد تنضموا الينا من بورسودان ماتيلد
المناصره في المجلس النرويجي للاجئين
مرحبا بك سيده ماتيلز ارقام مخيفه طبعا
للمعاناه الانسانيه ماذا عن حجم الدعم
والمساعدات
وشكرا على الاستضافه كما قلت ان هذه
الارقام مفزعه وغير مسبوقه لا اعتقد اننا
راينا ازمه بهذا المستوى من قبل في هذه
القاره وخاصه ان هذه الارقام التي لم
نراها لاكثر من عشر سنوات في السودان الان
الازمه الانسانيه مرعبه وما يؤسفنا انه
والامر مؤسف للناس الذين يهربون من
منازلهم ليس نهايه الكابوس قد يصلون الى
اماكن اكثر امانا لكنها ليست امنه اذ ان
فرقنا الان تعمل في مناطق النيل الابيض
حيث هنالك مواسم المطر والاشخاص الذين
نجحوهم يواجهون الفيضانات ويواجهون
الانتشار وتفشي الكوليرا والحصبه ويعانون
من نقص التغذيه وقد لا يموتون بسبب الرصاص
لكنهم قد
دون حياتهم لسبب الجوع اي او بسبب الظروف
الصعبه وللاسف فان
الاستجابه الانسانيه بشكل عام
صغيره مقارنه بحجم الاحتياجات لان العادات
كبيره والناس
يهربون من الخرطوم ومن دارفور ومن ايضا
مناطق الكثير من الاماكن
لسوء الحظ لا يمكن ان يصل اليها تصل اليه
المساعدات الانسانيه ما تفسير قله
المساعدات الوارده الى السودانيين
هنالك عده اسباب اولها ان هنالك مثلا
اعدام للامن مثلا في جنوب دارفور والتي
كانت كان هنالك قتال مكثف فيها في العاصمه
يالا وكانت من الصعب جدا
لاصول المنظمات الانسانيه ان تصل الى تلك
المناطق بالمساعدات والشاحنات التي تم
تحميلها بتلك المساعدات لمن يحتاجها اذ ان
هذه الشاحنات لم تصل الى تلك المناطق بسبب
النزاع ايضا انعدام الامن سبب اخر قضيه
اخرى ان السودان هي كبيره مساحه وهنالك
الكثير من القضايا اللوجستيه فيما يتعلق
بامكانيه الوصول الى بعض الاماكن وبعض
الاماكن تمت لا يمكن الوصول اليها بسبب
الامطار وايضا من الصعب الوصول الى داخل
البلد ونقل التجهيزات ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك من بورت سودان اذا ماتيل
مديره المناصره في المجلس النرويجي
للاجئين
[موسيقى]
واننا سنظل بحاجه الى ادوات لمكافح